hi guys welcome to the just pearly songs
youtube channel
today i'm going to be reacting
to kevin samuels the reason being okay
last time i reacted to kevin samuels a
lot of people said i misinterpreted him
that i didn't really understand his
message and you know oh shoot
you know i'm an understanding person
maybe i didn't so i'm about to watch
another video
and i'll let you know maybe i agree with
some of his stuff maybe i don't
but let me know in the comments below if
i'm right or
wrong also do not forget to follow me on
instagram a lot of these videos
come from submissions on instagram so if
you're not following me on instagram
you're not going to see the polls that i
do that decide what videos i'm reacting
to this week you're just not
so be a part of the process i want
feedback from all of you
let me know what videos i should react
to
this week okay i'm about to start
i cannot say what's wrong
okay can you hear me can you hear me now
those were hers hey can you hear me
yeah are you a phd ah no i'm a phd
how many dogs you got i won
really i'm sorry what kind of dog is it
he's a cane corso he's a what
a cane corsa what is that in english
um it's a larger dog and their breed is
meant for
guarding and protecting they're very
protective of their home and their
families
so what's your disagreement um honestly
i don't have a disagreement i just came
here because i honestly want some advice
from you
it says disagreement day i know this is
my first time catching
on live normally i'm asleep and um you
have a job
i do i own a business okay so i do too
and i do have a question but i have a
he's so mad
he's not happy that she
she did not listen business and if you
wanted my advice
you could always book a session if you
can't catch us at the show live
i'm definitely i was trying to go online
um earlier
but all you have to do man but see what
kind of business do you own
i own a pet grooming doggy daycare and
okay so
what you're basically trying to do is i
have a disagreement day and you
basically came in and said damn your
topic
i want to ask you what i want to ask you
and that's
but you are more than welcome to go on
my website and purchase your time to
talk with me one-on-one
because what you're trying to do is
rather rude but i will go ahead and do
it because i'm going to use this as a
teaching lesson
how
i i just knowing his demeanor like
i don't think this is gonna go well for
her how old are you
i'm 35 35 years old
35 years old and you're a business owner
uh-huh and what's your question um
so my issue is well i want to know
at what point when i'm just meeting a
guy do i tell him that i'm a
business owner because um my problem is
that
when i try to date down and i
the conversation comes up to where i own
a business
um the guy is either like hey can i come
join in on you on that business
or can i put someone and be a business
partner and
i'm not looking for that and i honestly
hold on hold on hold on hold on i need
to be clear on this subject where are
you where are you
at north carolina and you're saying
when to tell somebody you own a business
because um i find when i date down
god be of interest and want to be like a
business partner
and um i'm learning that maybe i need a
high value man because that's
well first off um
ma'am i really don't understand uh what
kind of man are you
talking about because
owning a business is no different than
having a job in my opinion
i'm not getting what you're saying when
should you i'm not understanding why
this is an issue
if you're if you're what kind of men are
you what kind of men are you dating
um i try to give i try to give guys that
not
that's not on my level a chance why
what do you mean on your level what does
that mean that's
making six figures or more
but i don't under okay you try to give
guys who are
not on your level a chance why and i'm
because i want i honestly wanna a sixth
speaker guy
uh is what i'm realizing okay so let me
just go ahead and net it out for you
you ready uh-huh
the guys you want aren't asking you out
well i'm i haven't been putting myself
out there honestly
but you put yourself out there enough
for the guys you don't want or
believe you to ask you out those are
like guys i met online
right so again
the men you want are not asking you out
see you ladies do this okay okay i'm
just gonna pause it right there
i do agree uh with him here
like i think a lot of girls like think
they're on a certain level
even when they're not because like you
know guys will try to like
hook up with you that are like of a
certain standard
but they they don't date you so i think
a lot of girls especially get like
inflated egos
which i think is where he's going with
this um
i could i could see that let me see you
go and
deal with men who you feel are beneath
you
and then you ask how to fix them i'm not
beneath you
i don't know how to fix a guy that
doesn't that's down there that's not my
concern
the better question is why can't you get
a guy on your level
that's the real question well the first
year
well first of all i would tell you what
i said
in here automatically is a problem why
you would come onto a show that you know
was a disagreement day
it's selfish it's like well
yes ma'am it's like i want what i want
i don't i don't say things for no reason
that's why i asked you questions you're
35 years old a business owner
that means you understand what business
is you know this is a business
and i have a and i have a show title and
you said
damn your show title i want to talk to
you
but you could have went to my business
and booked time to talk to me but you
wanted what you wanted how you want it
i'm sorry no it's but and i'm
okay i i agree with the point he's
making like
a lot of people will try to get like
freebies
from businesses or like take advantage
of them instead of
paying for the service now i'm not gonna
lie
i love free stuff i'm not
i get like why she did what she did but
like that's kind of something you do
when you're 21
22 and broke not 35
and you make six figures just book the
session especially if she's saying
she makes six figures like she should
just book the session
i'm using this as lesson that's the
problem with too many of you black women
you don't do [ __ ] the right way with
black men
that was improper and when i even when i
told you the right way you still were
like uh well whatever
so i'mma use this when was the last time
you had a relationship
um like the end of last year around
december how long did it last
a year a year uh and was that man uh
did you go to college did i go to
college
yes no sir
okay and how long have you owned your
own business nine years
and how and how long have you been
making six figures or more
on the last three okay why do you need a
man making six figures
um because i'm finding out that the guys
that i think that's not is not working
out
what does it have to do with money
because i feel like um
i need a guide that i can respect and
admire
and i'm a [ __ ] invention and i want a
guy
that has that drive too and when he
doesn't i find myself
you know encouraging like hey babe you
can do this and you can do that
and then so in north carolina
what percentage of the population what
percentage of men in this country make
six figures or more okay i'm gonna pause
him right there
i don't understand if she makes six
figures why she didn't book the session
that should be nothing
somebody makes six figures for three
years
and also i would like to say it's
something that they don't point out when
you're like dating
men can make a lot of money but it's
about how much
you save and invest and grow a lot of
guys like
might not have the like salary that you
want but there's a lot of them that are
saving like 20 30 percent of their
income
and are frugal and make smart decisions
um
that can one if you make a lot of money
like help you out you know
like especially if they're frugal and
they're good with their money
like they can help you like i don't know
if you make more money like maybe grow
it better
and second off like i know a lot of guys
that make a lot of money and just spend
it
so it's not everything
i think it's like five percent i'm not
closer to 10 so oh 10
all right so the question is what do
those men
who make that kind of money who all
women tend to want
what do they want i
feel like they want arm candy somebody
who can um
have more to bring to the table than
just looks but
um also bring
balance to their life i feel like i can
help them out on
um okay slow down i'm not understanding
you said they want arm candy then you
contradicted yourself
you want but they want somebody to more
than just looks
yeah arm candy but something about you
know brain with
it and you know more in depth do you own
do you know any men who make six figures
or more
my dad and my uncle do you know
excuse me do you know any men that you
are related to that make six figures or
more
unrelated to yeah that you are not
related to
not on a personal level
so you don't know him you don't know
what they want
but you want him man
i'm going to suggest that you really
don't know
[Music]
what you want
and saying six figures is just something
that you
got taken from out there but i'm not
hearing this rooted to anything
but what do you want ultimately do you
want to be married children what
yes i want to be married do you want any
children
yes how many um
i have a son you know so
how's your son he's 13 where's the
father
he's not enough in his life
i said where's the father well
he's not like in it like i would like
him to be
all right so um go ahead and take this
down man
men who make the kind of money you're
talking about have options
and typically i don't want to deal with
women who are
have 13 year old sons who are used to
dating men who
this doesn't sound appealing
to the kind of man you're talking about
do you understand what i'm saying
yeah but um i was thinking once i start
booking session with you
that um i can't change men i know but
i can approve myself and i feel like i
have a lot to offer to those type of me
okay but yeah
the kid um
that that's hard i feel like god like
just in general like people
generally don't want to raise other
people's kids see
you should have stopped right there i
just told you i cannot change men
and you said once i book a session with
you i'm not a miracle worker
i'm telling you what they want and
you're still saying yeah but i want them
they don't want you
but i have been working on myself this
year and um
okay ma'am but okay
oh oh he just ruined her life oh my
goodness
i mean he's not wrong like i can't
okay i get that 35 13 year old son
with a sketchy father why would a man
who's in the top 10 of earners who women
across the country
want want that
um because i have a lot to offer
um i feel like do you want your son
to if you had a son making that kind of
money
would you want him to bring home a woman
who had a 13 year old son
from a sketchy father or would you
prefer him to get a woman who had no
children
who was younger and easier to get on his
program
yeah he's
when you say it like that like okay i
don't even disagree
like everyone thought i was coming for
kevin samuels last time but
th this video i actually don't disagree
with at all
depending on his age this is see what i
mean
see what i mean this goes so deep for
black women
they will even that should have been an
easy question
no i would not want my son to bring i
want the best for my son
that should have been the appropriate
answer that's why i sat
up that is [ __ ]
you should want the best for your son of
course
but this is but and are you thinking
michael if he brought in
yes i feel like i'm the accept
no you're not that's the problem you all
think you're the exception to the rule
but but your life is proven to you that
you're not
my love life is not that good i agree
with you that's my point and ma'am and
that's my
point you ladies all feel like listen
you ladies all feel like you're the
exception to the rule
and then when someone like myself comes
along and gives you
a a dose of reality instead of just
accepting it it's like yeah but
yeah but i'm special you don't
know any men on this level
that are not your father that aren't
related to you that means you don't
know these men you don't know where to
go get them you don't know what they
want
but you're still saying pick me they
don't want
mid 30 year old baby mamas are trying to
be polite man but they don't want those
i ask you a question did you hear what i
said
oh my gosh i think i would cry i think i
would cry if someone said that
i don't know i don't know a lot of
people were telling me to go on his show
and i i'm actually open to the idea to
like go on a live or something with him
only because like on different points
that i disagree with but like
i don't have kids but if i was like a 35
year old baby mama and that was my
situation like
i would i might cry
yes why is that so okay go ahead
um
my from my point of view i feel like i i
get what you're saying
they they do have better options but
also those better options
are younger girls those younger girls
don't necessarily
are necessarily 20 year olds are not
necessarily attracted to 45 year olds
[ __ ] i'm 51. and i can't beat them
off with a stick
okay i never like was into older guys
when i was that age
so i don't that's what he's saying he
can't beat him off with a stick or
whatever but like
seriously like i never was into the old
guy thing like
i remember being like 22 and i was
dating a guy like i was going on dates
with a guy that was like 32
and i just felt so weird about it so i
was like oh my gosh she's like 10 years
older than me that's so old and he has
to be immature if he can like connect
with me
that's genuinely like how i felt that's
another one on you lies
no younger women are always the younger
women are attracted to older men what
are you talking about
so can you see me yes i can
okay so do you feel like a woman like me
uh what would you rank yourself on a
scale from one to ten
you cannot use seven would i rate myself
just your face uh my face when i wake up
five but when i put myself together six
okay
and how tall are you five five
dress size i'm sorry your dress size
okay so that makes you if you give
yourself a five
that's average yes so
average looking women tend not to get
high earning men
they tend to get average men
stop right there stop right there stop
right there
breathe and digest
you're 35 years old and you can look
around and see the world
you don't tend to see higher earning men
with average looking women
off rip if you do see them
they got them they got their average
looking woman when they were both
really young and he built his way up but
a man earning the kind of money you're
talking about
does not go for an average looking woman
damn damn
um
i would say okay i agree with him like
on some level but
the one part i would disagree is that i
think a lot of like
the nerdier like guys
date average looking girls all the time
like the guys that are kind of shy like
a little socially awkward
like there's a lot of them that are
really smart like computer software
engineers or like
you know data analysts whatever that are
pretty like normal guys
don't really spend a lot of money go to
work come home
like they're not dating like super
bottles but yeah like
some level yeah i mean my body is not
average so
but ma'am you please don't make me say
it
say what
i really just wanted some advice i love
you i'm giving you i'm giving you advice
but you're not
taking it the advice is man ma'am
you're average looking at best
i'm taking it in but okay but you're not
accepting the fact that okay
average looking women average looking
woman who's
older average looking older woman
with a 13 year old son
average looking woman with a 13 year old
son with a sketchy baby daddy
and now she's texting like mid oh gosh
i feel like and he's just laying this
all out
this gets worse every time i say
something
and now you're asking for a man who's in
the top 10
of men you don't
qualify for one
and you're making i mean i don't i don't
want to have to go there
but when you put in all these other
factors
why can't you just get a man that's an
average guy
sometimes i feel like um
in order to fully submit i have to feel
like he's in
well then you're gonna then you're gonna
die alone how about that
let me just cut to the chase man uh you
can feel like what you want to
but women like you die alone straight up
because you think you're better than the
men that you qualify for
and the only reason honestly ma'am that
i can see a woman like yourself
really thinking you deserve more is
because you earn more because you earn
more money than most people around you
in north carolina
damn damn oh my goodness
that's wild that's so wild
but if your ass worked at the post
office you would not think so highly
of your opportunities
why is she typing and that's the reality
we don't men
don't care about your money not the kind
of mean that you want we don't care
about your money
it ain't ours we care about the fact
that you are older
and you got kid
and your average
and your reality of your life has showed
you that
you don't have the kind of meaning that
you want knocking on your door trying to
find you
this goes back to what i was saying
earlier is again
i feel like a lot of girls like think
that certain guys are on their level
even though they're not because guys
will give them like attention because
they want to hook up with them
um i don't know if that's the case for
her because she says she doesn't know
any guys that make six
six figures but yeah
just my two cents see what we've done in
this country
this world is we've told women like
yourself
that you can have it all and you got a
prince charming
who's six foot a hundred six feet tall
six figure income jawline all this other
kind of stuff and i'm sorry man
no most people get average people
especially average people you're an
average person
i mean let's be real you're not running
microsoft you got you had a pet grooming
business
you've been making six figures for the
last three years
okay
but if i'm looking at you but if i
looked at you and i took all that off of
you
all the eyelashes and all the hair what
do you look like under there
i mean i look the same no you don't
because if you did you wouldn't have all
that on oh
i okay i hate when girls wear fake
eyelashes like
i've always just been into like minimal
makeup it's partially because i'm kind
of a tomboy
but like i do not
understand why girls like cake on the
makeup i'm sorry
no you don't you don't look the same
because if you did you wouldn't have all
that on
so what is your advice for
uh all right i'll tell you my advice man
because you're not listening to me
that's why i always recommend you need
you [ __ ] need therapy every people
think
most of us in black community need
therapy but you're not you're not
dealing with reality
i asked you about your child's father
and you couldn't answer me
but it doesn't sound like you're too
proud of him
how's it what kind of student is your
child
he's a student does he have any
behavioral problems
no he actually got a youtube channel and
he's trying to i don't need to i don't
need no no
no but where is it but his daddy is
still
if his daddy is alive does he have a
relationship with his father
then what's your issue with him
um he's not um business-minded like my
father and my uncle and
then why did you choose to make a baby
with him before you got married
young and dumb i was 16. exactly and
that cost
see that dumb [ __ ] let me stop you right
here that young and dumb [ __ ] you black
women throw out
as if it's supposed to give listen and
listen well
women young and dumb is not a get out of
jail free card
it doesn't go woof and change the fact
you still have to carry that consequence
no he's
i like really don't disagree with
anything he's saying
like it's true if you have a kid young
um and like the only thing is if you
look at life there's a benefit to
everything
she wants to have like more kids so
that's that's kind of her problem but
like
she could be like done and just date a
guy that like doesn't want more kids so
it's like a bit older than her
in my opinion right it's probably
i don't know if that would work but
that's what i would think maybe
and men are not rushing up to be
stepfathers to
13 year olds
what would be better is if you honestly
sat down and
asked yourself what value can i bring to
a man
and i know that what i can well
all right what can what value what what
is it
what is it i can help him with this
business
i'm very business minor on the um end of
health and organize but she's not
listening kevin samuels is saying that
men don't care
about your like finances your money
whatever
which okay i would disagree on some
level just because i have like brothers
that make a lot of money or like my
brothers made a lot of money and the
amount of girls that he like
dumped in college because he thought
they were stupid like nothing to do with
the way they looked
nothing to do with anything he just
literally thought they were dumb so and
they're beautiful but dumb
so erin i plant
um into planting my own garden so
i can definitely plant i'm into um
improving my elegance with um
just self-improvement and working on
myself and
ma'am at 35 years old at 35 years old
here's what you told me
i can help him with his business due
respect ma'am
um and i mean no disrespect but 20 to 30
of people own businesses what about the
70 to 80 of men who don't own them
that means that it doesn't matter
that means nothing to the average man
then the next thing you said i can plant
man that means nothing to most people
because we go to grocery stores
then you say self-improvement you've had
i gave you a shot at saying what you
have to offer to me
and you said nothing that we value
what do you know what i'm going to book
a session bigger session
i'm not doing this nope nope nope nope
i'm done
he gave me like 20 minutes this happens
the older you ladies
get the more you get set in your ways
book a session because i don't want to
do this in public man
cause you seem like a sweet woman but
you don't but you're not getting it
you're being so mean i'm not being don't
tell me i'm being mean
i'm about to be mean i get tired of you
broads
telling me i'm being mean because you
cannot handle the damn truth
you called my show on the day the
training was supposed to be here
and i honored the call and sat here and
tried to help you and i'm telling you
telling me i'm being mean and she's
still on her phone
tired of doing this [ __ ] oh she did not
know this was about to get a million
views
okay um second reaction to kevin samuels
i agreed with a lot of the things he
said like i'd say there's small
disagreements here and there
um i don't know if i specifically know
what he means when he says high value
because
i would say that like what you value is
different
like from person to person um
but yeah like i don't i don't disagree
with anything she said
i feel bad for that girl because she
probably did not know
that she was about to get called ugly in
front of millions of people
but then she probably shouldn't have
called so let me know in the comments do
you guys agree with my analysis do you
disagree where did i miss it um
also do not forget to subscribe to the
channel follow me on instagram
and comment what video you want me to
react to next time
i'll talk to you guys later
you